my first job out of college I was a high
school teacher so I was 21 teaching 17
and 18 year olds yeah and I tell people
out there always like Natasha that must
have been so hard how did you get kids
to pay attention to you honestly it's
really not that hard all you have to do
is kiss them on the lips
[Music]
[Applause]
and I don't like judging by that
sweatshirt aren't you already like a
super successful middle school gym
teacher and it's like I wish I moved
here six months ago and I have no
friends or plans or obligations or
relationships to keep up when I look in
the mirror I'm like whoa I'm so diverse
and that should be on TV what the
I think I'm perfect for season four of
charm Academy I got an attitude your
girl dreams of
[Music]
you should totally pick me to be in the
digital creators program
look at these lockers I'm still in high
school I'm young
imagine a show where I interview JLo on
the beach and get this every single
episode huh so now have a radio show on
Tommy's infra radio but this opportunity
seems cool we have everything you want
any young internet star I'm younger than
three years old I just want to know what
it's like to interview comedians that
aren't drunk if you want this thing to
succeed on YouTube you need someone to
spread fear and conspiracy theories oh
geez oh geez oh geez
[Music]
hi I'm Jordan I'm kind of funny one at
comedy central to get as many people
Philadelphia working in this building as
possible and bad I'd be like you know
choked me but I love you so much I never
want to hurt you and I feel like okay
get off me I can't breathe I just don't
feel like anybody's taking me seriously
like I live by high school and all the
kids we're getting out this lady came
out of the school and she's like y'all
need to move y'all gonna move you you
got to move I was like oh no I'm a grown
man she said excuse me I said haha I'm
uh
I'm a man and then she said come here
and then she wrote me up so I've got
detention after this
we have some good news for you
[Applause]
[Music]